bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo avec comme chaque
semaine à mes côtés au de moura qui ni
bonjour ni quel genre à tous et dans
l'actualité cette semaine et bien on va
se poser une question à qui la faute
au lendemain de son élimination du
premier tour des législatives partielles
à villeneuve sur lot le ps cherche des
explications
certains y voient une séquelle de la
sphère cahuzac d'autres pointent du
doigt la multiplicité des candidatures à
gauche en tout cas rares sont ceux qui
procèdent à une introspection
on en parle depuis des semaines cette
fois c'est fait les députés ont examiné
le projet de loi sur la transparence de
la vie publique
oui à une déclaration de patrimoine
simplement consultable en préfecture oui
à la publication des déclarations
d'intérêts plusieurs députés auraient
souhaité aller plus loin sans succès
enfin nous célébrons dans peu de temps
le centenaire de la guerre 14 18 et bien
cette occasion sa chute le sénat a
décidé d'ouvrir ses archives
vous pouvez les consulter sur le site
internet du sénat et bien c'est qu'une
première est avec nous pour commenter
toute cette actualité luc carvounas
bonjour vous êtes sénateur socialiste du
val-de-marne
élu depuis octobre 2011 vous occupez au
parti socialiste le poste stratégique de
secrétaire national aux relations
extérieures on l'assuré quel syndicat
avec les parties vous allez nous
expliquer exactement en quoi cela
consiste mais avant nous sommes allés
demander à quelques sénateurs ce qu'il
pensait de vous regarder c'est quelqu'un
qui est conviviale sérieux et qui sait
aller au fond de ces dossiers
c'est un homme de terrain de ce côté là
je crois que c'est un très bon diplomate
il est sympa comme tout
convivial souriant de bonne humeur et on
s'amuse bien
il a déjà des capacités diplomatiques et
le sens de l'écouté
il est très ferme très très dur dans sa
vision de rapport de force du parti
socialiste et des partenaires mais c'est
bien légitime il est là pour ça
après il sait trouver les équilibres oui
c'est respecter la diversité les
sensibilités c'est pour moi ou quelqu'un
qui a beaucoup de sens de l'équilibré
courrier à y compris je suis un jeu
semaine ses amis alors luc carvounas on
n'a pas eu de chance on a un truc des
avis positifs généralement on aime bien
avoir de tout vous nous connaissez
on entend les écologistes l'acquis qui
sont plutôt élogieux c'était un peu un
exploit parce que les écologistes sont
rarement élogieux avec leurs partenaires
socialistes
vous avez ce sens comme ça de la rondeur
avec eux et en quoi consiste exactement
votre job
mon job que m'a confié harlem désir le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
s'inscrit dans le droit fil de ce qu'ont
fait mes prédécesseurs et je pense
notamment à claude bartolone qui avait
en son temps occupé ces fonctions
c'est d'être un intermédiaire quand ça
va bien mais aussi quand ça va mal de se
dire les choses avec mes homologues des
autres partis et puis d'accompagner la
direction nationale mais pas seul avec
mes amis alain fontanel christophe
borgel pour la préparation des élections
évidemment municipal prochaine
diplomatique on entend ça veut dire quoi
et diplomatique vous savez mettre un
petit peu d'eau dans votre vol ben oui
quand on fait de la plainte article il
faut j'espère avoir un peu de sens de la
diplomatie sinon comme on dit il faut
changer de métier maintenant moi j'ai un
logiciel qui a toujours été de
fonctionner dans les additions plutôt
que dans les soustractions donc fort de
ce logiciel là j'essaye à la place qui
est la mienne de rassembler de mettre
autour d'une table de se dire clairement
je suis d'une génération qui dit les
choses avec le vérité on tourne pas
autour du pot vaut mieux appeler un chat
un chat un chat un chien au moins ça a
le mérite de soir dogon paris ce qu'on
veut chercher ensemble ou pas trouvé le
chemin commun voilà c'est ce que
j'essaye relations avec vos alliés aussi
vous allez aussi essayé d'amadouer les
parlementaires ump
comment ça se passe ma fonction au sein
du parti socialiste et de discuter avec
les partis de gauche
imaginez pas autre chose mais encore
moins avec le modem voient là vous voyez
je vous dis que je mets les pieds dans
le plat n'avait pas l'intérêt et le rôle
du parti socialiste pour le reste je
discute avec mes collègues de
l'opposition sénatoriale dans
l'hémicycle dans les couloirs du sénat
mais ça ça fait partie de la courtoisie
du job du mandat de parlementaire c'est
la courtoisie républicaine et puis si
aussi important de parler entre entre la
majorité et l'opposition dans
l'hémicycle mais personne bien bolduc
arunas sans langue de bois vous êtes un
très proche de manuel valls on le sait
il est très haut dans les sondages
est ce que ça faisait ça facilite un
petit peu le rapport avec les autres en
ce moment où pas coutume je ne sais pas
- je sais par contre qu'il ya quelques
années où on nous disait on disait de
manuel valls qu'il était en dehors des
clous pas dans le parti socialiste un
peu trop bas et je suis pas si
l'amendement tous les cas c'est un mini
ce qui prouve que l'on peut réussir la
politique du gouvernement et celle
voulue par le président et par les aides
ça facilite peut-être quelques quelques
relations mais maintenant vous savez
nous et moi en particulier je le dis
souvent pour avoir été le directeur de
sa campagne moment des primaires
citoyennes jeu c'est de nous sommes
partis nous étions sept petites tpe et
aujourd'hui je suis fier de voir que
manuel valls richie communiste de
l'intérieur je heureux de voir les
sondages d'opinion qui sont très
favorables vaut mieux avoir ce sondage
là et c'est important pour la ligne
gouvernementale
maintenant nous nous enivre ont pas de
ces chiffres est en tous les cas à la
place qui est la mienne
à ses côtés modestement je m'enivre pas
mais je les regarde avec beaucoup de
satisfaction alors roulé un peu tout le
fil de l'actualité de cette semaine on
commence bien sûr par le lundi avec une
nouvelle législative perdue pour la
gauche
la ville de villeneuve sur lot était au
centre de toutes les attentions ces
derniers temps c'était l'ancien fief de
jérôme cahuzac
le candidat ps lui n'a pas pu se
maintenir au premier tour alors à qui la
faute
pourquoi cette dispersion de voix
réponse en tout cas avec betty lachguer
dans l'ancien fief de jérôme cahuzac la
défaite était bel et bien prévisible
pour le ps son candidat bernard barral
n'est arrivé qu'en troisième position
avec 23 points 69 % des voix impact de
la sphère cahuzac forte abstention et
division de la gauche
la sanction est sans surprise mais
difficile à encaisser pour le parti
socialiste qui demande à faire barrage
au fn
c'est un courant politique qui
représente les pages les plus sombres de
notre histoire
il faut cesser de le banaliser
n'attendons pas un réveil douloureux
pour jean françois copé cette défaite
est un nouveau désaveu cinglant pour
françois hollande et son gouvernement il
appelle au vote utile espère que les
consignes du ps seront adoptées donc
j'espère que le parti socialiste dans
cette affaire ne s'égare rap a une
nouvelle fois lui qui est si prompt à
demander aux autres ce qu'ils ne
s'appliquent pas à lui-même
ce sera donc un duel ump fn au second
tour
arrivée légèrement devant jean louis
costes sait qu'il devra compter sur les
voix de la gauche pour l'emporter au
second tour derrière le candidat ump
appelé au front républicain
jamais le front national n'a fait des
scores aussi élevé dans ce dans ce
territoire la 7e circonscription dans
cette aquitaine qui est un territoire de
migration territoire d'immigration
depuis depuis maintenant plusieurs
siècles d'avoir aujourd'hui un front
national c'est dramatique dramatique est
dangereux pour la démocratie
des propos que n'a pas apprécié le front
national alors que son candidat etienne
bousquet cassagne a réalisé dimanche
soir une performance en arrivant second
avec plus de 26 % des voix ils se
ridiculisent parce que ça démontre
qu'ils ont eu un problème avec la
démocratie
s'il n'accepte pas qu'il ait en face un
candidat patriots un candidat national
sinon pas trop d'autres arguments de
fond à donner aux français pour essayer
de les convaincre c'est qu'ils sont
totalement panique
y aura-t-il un troisième députés
frontistes à l'assemblée nationale
réponse ce dimanche
c'est la huitième législatives d'affilée
perdus pour les socialistes ça commence
à faire beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup et en même temps qu'on
avait peut-être les un moule et les
autres oublier ce que faisait l'effet
induit de l'élection d'un président
socialiste
la vague rose on avait peut-être pas
forcément en tête d'avoir ce résultat-là
en juin 2012
on oublie aussi ce qu elles refluent
c'est à dire quand on est plus dans le
contexte de la gagne 2,2 du 6 mai et
qu'on l'ait dans un rééquilibrage dans
des circonscriptions qui était très à
droite leur mission dès sa conception
particulière celle de jérôme cahuzac
mais c'est un récit un reflux qui
revient à une sociologie électorale pour
les cantons regarde les sept autres
circonscriptions rebuy c'est ce que vous
excluez retour à la normale électorale
dans ces circonscriptions sur la
circonscription de jaune cayzac on est
dans un contexte très très différent où
on va pas redire ce qui s'est produit a
été 1,6 dans l'histoire la vème
république des six comme ça là et
heureusement on n'a pas tant que ça et
aujourd'hui on a un électorat et des
citoyens totalement désabusés par
rapport à un homme qui a menti mais
maintenant on le laisse à son affaire
personnelle et à la justice moi je
commenterai pas ça et on est dans un
contexte électoral compliqué où
l'abstention va être notre pire ennemi
face à ce qui peut se produire dimanche
prochain le parti socialiste harlem
désir et tous les progressistes ont été
claires pour faire un front républicain
contre le candidat du front national
j'espère que dimanche soir prochain il
n'y aura pas un croisé dans tous les cas
nous ouvrons nous faisons le travail
pour que nous puissions mobiliser nos
électeurs mal de résistance sur le
terrain il y à de la résistance mais il
y aussi un un contexte où on n'oublie
pas ce que je romps cahuzac il faut lui
rendre le fait qu'il avait à six sept
circonscriptions à gauche c'est mon
collègue présent la commission défense
jean-louis carrère qui nous rappelait il
ya quelques jours au bureau
groupe au sénat que le lot et garonne
c'est un département assez marquée par
une histoire et une extrême droite
c'était y'a pas si loin que ça une
vingtaine d'années déjà
le front national dont là oublié envoyer
des conseillers régionaux issus de ce
secteur-là bontemps professeur agrégé
gars il ya un ancrage d'extrême droite
qu'on a peut-être un peu électoralement
oublié parce qu un vrai travail de
terrain fait par jérôme cahuzac qui a
assisté de circonscription il ya quand
même un une réalité politique
territoriale et notamment cette montée
du front national que ce soit dans cette
région ou une autre c'est une crainte
pour vous en vue des municipales
prochaines échéances 2014
bien sûr c'est une crainte et je me
souviens qu'en 2007 nicolas sarkozy
avait été élu président la république
que n'avait-on pas entendu que il avait
siphonné le front national que le front
national était mort sauf que nicolas
sarkozy pendant cinq ans a mis en oeuvre
une politique avec les théories de
dubuisson qui aujourd'hui ont une
porosité dans l'ump tels que la droite
républicaine le curseur de l'électorat
de la droite républicaine est en train
de se déplacer là aussi pas fait grand
chose non plus parce que c'est vous
pouvez dire c'est de la faute de nicolas
sarkozy c'est aussi de la faute du parti
socialiste si aujourd'hui front national
a donc la faute du parti socialiste mais
parti socialiste est forcément le front
national n'ont plus le goût du parti
socialiste a plus que combattu le front
national je pense que nous sommes loin
d'être ceux qui avons fait grandir le
parti de marine le pen qui vient c'est
ce que dit le père force est de
constater si on regarde les résultats
électoraux des dernières législatives
celle de juin 2012
quand il s'agissait de des reports de
voix des électeurs du candidat ump au
premier tour vers les candidats du front
national qui se maintenait au deuxième
tour vous voyez que les les passages
existe aujourd'hui ne pas le reconnaître
c'est laissé entendre que rien ne se
passe il faut combattre l'extrême droite
le parti socialiste le fait avec force
et vigueur à voir venir à cette défaite
locale ce serait aussi pour certains
socialistes la faute des écologistes ils
ont beau être au gouvernement il
n'aurait pas joué franc jeu en
présentant leur propre candidat à la
partielle bruno le roux président du
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée parle de
faute politique il aurait fallu partir
unie
la bataille voici ce qu'en pense à cette
semaine à l'assemblée françois de rugy
le coprésident du parti écologiste
on est resté toujours fidèle au poste
envers et contre tout les difficultés
car il y en a beaucoup des difficultés
économiques sociales mais aussi des
difficultés politiques et qui ne datent
pas de cette élection partielle là il y
en avait déjà eu d'autres à d'autres
élections partielles
et puis il ya des tensions aussi parfois
organisés on a l'impression au sein même
du gouvernement
mais ce que nous disons c'est que pour
réussir il nous semble que 1
il faut se remettre en question on ne
peut pas se faire la politique de
l'autruche et 2
il faut en discuter entre nous là c'est
du boulot pour vous appuyez vous êtes
chargé de mettre du liant entre les
parties du timbre une route parlé de
faute politique d'écouté bruno le roux
président du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale a donné son opinion et son
analyse de ce qui a été inséré citic de
boucs émissaires sont allés dire 900 les
autres qui sont responsables
non non d'abord je pense pas qu'on
cherche un bouc émissaire surtout quand
on je disais tout à l'heure je cherche à
rassembler ses pop up c'est pas pour
dire maintenant que c'est la faute des
uns et des autres forces et quand même
de constater ce que nous avons tous
regretté les socialistes harlem désir
bruno le roux moi même c'est qu'on n'ait
pas réussi à se rassembler et puis
longtemps je pense qu'il ya eu une
erreur d'analysé lectorale sur cette
circonscription de la part de mes amis
d'europe écologie les verts 2,8 pour
cent c'est pas ça qui aurait changé
d'avis qu'ils ont quand même fait une
erreur d'analysé pourquoi parce que dans
l'oise à la législative partielle nous
sommes rassemblés parce qu'ils avaient
reconnu qu'il y avait un danger front
national ils ont fait une appréciation
de considérer qu'il n'y avait pas de
dents chez les front national sur cette
élection partielle
et donc ils sont partis en campagne je
pense que cette erreur d'appréciation a
fait une dispersion de nos forces et que
l'élan était pas là pour donner la gagne
un candidat district mans ça n'aurait
pas changé les choses et le parti
socialiste ne l'a contacté afin de
conduire ce pays n'aurait pas été colis
des résultats d'un dimanche soir moi
j'embarque de l'élan d'une campagne qui
aurait été tout autre
la dynamique aurait été différent mais
pour la suite ça donne quoi avec les
municipales là encore sur la même
question tout à l'heure
ce que vous formulez municipal nous nous
travaillons que ce soit avec le front de
gauche tendance parti communiste puisque
ce sont eux les concernés se eux qui ont
dérivé des élus locaux et avec europe
ecologie les verts mais aussi avec le
muc donc ça serait dur abbas à ce que
vous dites
nous travaillons rassemblement de toutes
les forces de gauche dès le premier tour
déjà dans les villes dirigée par un
maire ou une mère de gauche sortants et
qui souhaitent repartir et dans des
bastions de droite qui nous que nous
pourrions faire basculer dans nos
échanges qui sont les nôtres c'est de
regarder qui chez nous est le plus à
même d'être le chef de file comme on dit
au parlement pour emmener unis qui peut
rassembler pour conquérir de nouveaux
territoires à gauche assez de la
diplomatie allez on passe au mardi les
députés votent la transparence en tous
cas presque
les députés examinent effectivement
cette semaine un texte qui dès concerne
au plus haut point la transparence de la
vie publique en ce mardi ils votent la
consultation de leur patrimoine en
préfecture et non la publication comme
le voulaient le gouvernement et il
s'attaque également aux volets des
conflits d'intérêts explication du and
roll à des échanges plus longs et
souvent plus vif que prévu si l'adoption
des deux premiers articles de la loi est
désormais officielle certains
amendements pourtant défendue par des
députés de la majorité ont
définitivement été repoussés dans
l'hémicycle à commencer par celui
d'olivier fort en faveur de la publicité
de l'évolution des patrimoines des
députés durant leur mandat est une
partie du patrimoine qui relève de la
vie d'avant celle qu'on avait avant
d'être élu et puis il y a ensuite la
part du patrimoine qui est son
accroissement pendant le mandat et qui
relève la de la transparence nous devons
nos concitoyens le sujet le plus houleux
de la soirée comment concilier le rôle
de parlementaire avec une autre activité
professionnelle dans ce domaine
le gouvernement et le président de la
république souhaitait des interdictions
draconiennes pour éviter tout conflit
d'intérêts l'assemblée se contentera
d'une interdiction de débuter tout
nouveau métier pendant la durée du
mandat dispositions très chahutées
quand toute sa vie on a exercé
c'est des fonctions politiques et tout
d'un coup après avoir exercé des
fonctions gouvernementales
on se retrouve à monter une activité de
conseil alors qu'on en a jamais mené
jusqu alors vous allez m'expliquer alors
que vous êtes parlementaire qu'elle est
tout d'un coup la vertu extraordinaire
qui vous permet où cette espèce de
transe en danse qui vous permet tout
d'un coup d'exercice des activités de
conseil qui sont financés par de grands
groupes avec lesquels vous avez eu des
relations partir d'une manière générale
et faire un procès d'intention aux
professionnels du droit
je vois pas au nom de quoi on peut se
permettre cela alors que toutes les
professions peuvent être concernés d'une
manière ou d'une autre
cet après-midi le tempo des débats
devrait s'accélérer il sera question de
la mise en place de la haute autorité
chargée de contrôler les déclarations
des élus
alors les députés ont achevé l'examen du
texte mercredi soir il ya très
clairement des avancées consultation des
patrimoines publication des déclarations
d'intérêt interdiction d'exercer des
activités de conseil protection des
lanceurs d'alert donc on peut dire quand
même qu'il y à des avancées il faut pas
tout jeter
mais aussi beaucoup d'amendements
recalés est-ce que ça va arriver au
sénat très bientôt est ce que le groupe
socialiste au sénat l'intention d'aller
plus loin que l'on fait les députés ou
pas objectivement n'en n'a pas encore
débattu entre nos tout cas au groupe
socialiste le sujet va arriver mais sait
on débat de beaucoup de sujets en ce
moment au parlement mais il va arriver
en son temps moi je vois quoi que sur
les sujets comme la transparence toutes
les manières dans une démocratie comme
la nôtre on n'en fera jamais assez
quel que soit ce que l'on va voter on
aura toujours une majorité
prenons des exemples concrets la
publication des patrimoines telle
qu'elle a été demandé vous moi je suis
satisfait non j'étais sur la position de
claude bartelone moi je suis satisfait
que la déclaration pratique parce qu'il
y avait un côté voyeuriste qui me plaît
sa part à m'sila
il a raison moi ça fait partie il faut
faire attention à ne pas abîmer nos
institutions
les femmes et les hommes qui s'engagent
en politique
nous nous engageons au politique parce
que nous croyons pouvoir être utile à
l'intérêt général à nos collectivités ou
par le monde pour notre pays
on n'a rien volé on a gagné une élection
on est sur un mandat déterminé imaginer
qu'avec ce besoin de transparence je
vais faire un petit arrangement entre
amis les vous savez que depuis 2008 moi
par exemple j'ai déjà déclaré 4 x 4 fois
quand j'ai été élu conseiller général la
première fois au renouvellement en 2011
quand j'ai été élu maire sénateur en 1er
octobre d'union et quand j'ai été élu
maire en mars 2012 en 4 x 4 fois en
quatre ans j'ai déclaré tout mon
patrimoine ça existent aujourd'hui par
rapport à la sphère cahuzac
ça a été un tel séisme qu'il a fallu
apporter une réponse urgente insultant
c'est la réponse à un autre exemple
parce qu'il faut être très concret sur
ce genre d'affaires les écologistes
avaient proposé un amendement demandant
de justifier ses indemnités de frais de
mandat ça a été recalé retoqué a priori
ça paraît pas à l'idée qu'une qu'ils ont
recalé ce type de ben non moi je suis
pour car là pour le coup c'est ce genre
de deux sujets qui sont pour moi des
noms sujet qui devrait être de fait qui
laisse croire ou prennent nos
concitoyens il ya un problème
évidemment qu'il faut justifier de
dépenses dans le cadre de nos frais
demandait c'est ce que vous pensez mais
les députés n'ont pas aimé cet
amendement du sénat on pourrait à notre
tour injecté à la maison ça fera partie
des discussions
je crois que sur encore une fois ce qui
relève du non sujet par rapport à ce qui
doit être notre idée de la tonicité de
notre démocratie il faut évacuer cela
est pas s'embourber et s'invectivent et
les uns les autres sur une forme de
concours lépine en fait du qui mieux
mieux parce que sur ceux qui mieux mieux
la justice arbitrale concours lépine je
vois à peu près à quoi vous pensez
puisque le nouvel observateur cette
semaine a demandé aux députés séparément
il faut le dire ce qu'il suggérait à
titre individuel pour améliorer encore
le texte sur la transparence dit
dix d'entre eux ont répondu dont l'ump
laurent wauquiez lui il aimerait qu'on
aligne le régime des retraites des
députés sur le régime de tous les
français
à écouter les eaux quatre colonnes c'est
juste avoir le même régime que tout
voilà qui ait pas d'ambiguïté qui est
pas de doute on est suffisamment dans
une crise de confiance entre les
français la politique pour essayer
d'améliorer notre fonctionnement alors
on sait que claude bartolone paris a
très mal pris ces espèces de concours
lépine dont vous parlez les retraites
prenant les retraites on va demander aux
français plus d'efforts à ce que cette
suggestion laurent wauquiez ne tombe pas
sous le sens aligner le régime les
députés sur le régime de tous les
français
je ne sais pas il faut regarder ce que
fait un député quand il est battu quelle
est la réalité qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
parce que le débat tel qu'il est posé
depuis maintenant longtemps c'est
toujours supprimés enlevez équilibré
mais je longeais oui c'est vrai pour
trouver je n'entends jamais comme on
appelle la rigueur mais je n'ai je
n'entends jamais comment avancer le
pouvoir pouvoirs du parlement
je n'entends jamais comment finalement
un député avec ses trois collaborateurs
dans un bureau ou un sénateur de 10
mètres carrés ce qui est mon cas
parce que je voudrais quand même que les
gens sachent que quand on parle du grand
pouvoir du législateur
c'est la réalité d'un bureau de 11
mètres car elle nous sommes quatre
dedans rien n'est fait rien n'est
organisé aujourd'hui mais matériellement
ou physiquement pour donner un pouvoir
de contrôle
quand j'entends le roi quand j'entends
le révoquer qui finalement le pauvre ne
sait plus quoi faire pour se faire
remarquer puisqu'il a bien compris il
n'y aura pas de primaires internes à
l'ump
bon il s'est démarqué au moment du
mariage pour tous bien lui plaisent ils
se démarquent maintenant à nouveau sur
le concours lépine bien lui plaît je
crois christian jacob ne le suis pas
beaucoup c'est il a l'air assez isolé
finalement laurence une réponse très
politique matin sur lui d'entendre
clairement concrètement si j'ai pas de
tabou s'il faudrait pas l'air d'accord
pour aligner un régime des députés
présidant jeudi que le débat des petites
il faut voir il faut voir pourquoi moi
je suis contre aucun débat - chez un
législateur je suis pour qu'on pose tout
sur la table et qu'on en parle
sereinement pas dans ce type de contexte
pas au moment où on est en train de
voter une loi dans un contexte qui est
celui de cahuzac tu vas transparence qui
était attendue de faire de la surenchère
ce n'est pas cessé durant chaque ce que
ça ne fait que favoriser les populismes
on parlait du front national tout à
l'heure il faut qu'à un moment donné les
parlementaires aient conscience d'abord
qu'ils sont l'état qu'ils ont un rôle à
jouer et qui conscientisent l'euro
l'institut
lionel plutôt que d'essayer de trouver
par je ne sais quelle opération de
communication à avoir une expression
singulière grâce à une communication ou
un vrai problème de génération on sent
que claude bartolone jean françois copé
eux étaient contre cette initiative mais
on voit que barbara pompili laurent
wauquiez eux sont plutôt pour tous ces
jeunes générations vous voyez là un
conflit ou pas moi j'ai une nature
je voulais dire à rassembler donc je
vais pas commencer à opposer les anciens
aux plus jeunes
d'abord je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
jeunes générations anciennes générations
enrichi sur nos différences
moi je dis simplement attention à mes
collègues nez aux parlementaires qui ont
été élus par des accords politiques je
pense notamment à mes amis d'europe
écologie les verts à d'autres collègues
parlementaires socialistes qui ont été
élus parce que imposé dans des
circonscriptions sans pas préalablement
avoir eu deux territoires de faire
attention à ne pas eux mêmes créé les
conditions d'une caste de nos
institutions
il faut que en toute chose garder agir
avec sérénité poser tous les tous les
sujets sans tabou sur la table
c'est en fait ces avancées sur un an oll
erreur c'est d'avoir répondu à ces
questions là dans un an au moment où ils
s'étaient eux-mêmes en train de voter la
loi et ming donc oui mauvais timing
parce que en plus insuffisantes
moi je me mets à la place de mon ami
olivier faure qui dans un premier temps
les gens ont pensé qu'elle avait signé
une tribune avec laurent wauquiez
personne n'y croyait
tous s'apprêtent à la confusion c'est
pas bien individuel voilà pourquoi on va
passer à un autre sujet cher à savoir si
les français sont réactionnaires vous
avez peut-être entendu ce mot cette
semaine c'est en tout cas on parle de
matière culturelle ce mot est venue de
josé manuel barroso le président de la
commission européenne ça vient après des
accords sur le libre échange entre
l'europe et les états unis et bien ce
mot à semer la zizanie ça on imagine
bien des explications de nathalie dit
ouah la france est-elle réactionnaire la
question fait débat et le ton entre
l'europe et la france
aujourd'hui olli rehn le commissaire
européen aux affaires économiques
étaient au sénat entendu par la
commission des finances il a tenu à
préciser les propos du président de la
commission européenne josé manuel
barroso et laisse planer un doute sur la
suite des négociations
la phrase a été sorti du contexte
comme je les dis la commission
européenne va travailler dans le cadre
défini la semaine dernière au conseil
des affaires étrangères les discussions
sur la diversité culturelle et
l'audiovisuel sont légitimes
même si françois hollande s'est expliqué
au g8 avec josé manuel barroso la
critique passe mal aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale c'est jean marc
ayrault qui a vivement défendu
l'exception culturelle française
il s'agit pas d'avoir peur l'exception
culturelle
c'est à dire d'affirmer que les biens
culturels ne sont pas des marchandises
comme les autres ça n'a rien de
réactionnaire au contraire c'est le
progrès c'est l'ouverture aux cultures
du monde
c'est la défense de la diversité
culturelle ça s'impose à tous aux mains
de la commission comme au président de
la commission européenne lui même un
discours visiblement pas entendu par
bruxelles
car la commission européenne affirme
aujourd'hui que l'accord conclu entre
les états membres de l'union européenne
pour exclure l'audiovisuel du champ des
négociations commerciales avec les états
unis n'est toujours pas définitif il est
choqué par ce mot réactionnaire ou pas
oh moi je pense que barroso a fait une
faute
on a beau nous expliquer tout ça est
sorti de son contexte nous donne le
sentiment de gérer sa sortie alors on
sait pas si ce sera à l'onu à l'otan
donc à quelques clins d'oeil il fait aux
états unis ou pas il faudrait qu'il
s'occupe un peu de notre europe et
l'exception culturelle c'est quelque
chose de très important et il faut
balayer regard non parce qu'on disait
buteur qu'il faut être concret moi si
j'avais pas l'exception culturelle dans
ma ville je n'aurais pas pu accompagner
le théâtre studio ça ne parlera pas ici
mais ça m'a permis de faire ce que je
n'aurais pas pu faire autrement qu'avec
l'exception culturelle
et ça c'est la richesse tout a été dit
par le premier ministre en donc il faut
préserver ça je vois pas comment la
culture et la mise de la culture hier
l'a dit dans l'hémicycle interrogé par
l'opposition au sénat on peut pas brader
la culture dans le libre échange cette
exception culturelle
elle est là elle est préservée comme un
talisman ça a été redit par nicole bricq
la semaine dernière
pour être très concret également sur ce
point vous n'avez pas peur que
stratégiquement ce soit aussi une erreur
de la france parce qu'une fois qu'on a
dit exception culturelle
eh bien on veut plus rien négocier
d'autres c'est à dire que du jour au
lendemain sur les accords sur
l'agriculture sur les accords
environnementaux sociétaux comprend plus
rien dire moi je fais confiance à ceux
qui vont négocier pour notre pays
en lieu et place il faut préserver ce
que l'exception culturelle c'est
infiniment important section serait
spécifiquement française en ouvrant une
brèche pour d'autres exceptions
éventuellement parce qu'on sait à
l'environnement les ogm d'état les
américains peuvent brandir des excès
parce que c'est notre histoire nous
sommes un vieux pays qui qui est
regardée dans le monde entier que ce
c'était en art là nous devons le
préserver et moi je serai ce avec
détermination qui feront en sorte de le
préserver
après vous avez raison de dire que ça
peut être dans le pot commun une contre
valeur ajoutée à d'éventuelles
négociations du boeuf aux hormones des
raisons de le dire ne pas le dire serait
faire de la langue de bois
maintenant il faut aussi prêter à ceux
qui vont négocier le talent de la
négociation pour que nous nous y
retrouvions complètement passée au
mercredi après la transparence le cumul
des mandats encore un sujet qui fâche
la commission des lois attaque l'examen
ce mercredi d'un texte phare du
programme hollande la fin du cumul des
mandats le ministre de l'intérieur
manuel valls est venu présenter le
projet devant les députés interdiction
de cumuler un mandat parlementaire avec
un mandat d'exécutif local une mesure
qui s'appliquerait en 2010 est donc
après les prochaines élections
municipales
mais avec des obligations dès la
campagne municipale écouter vers le
ministre et parlementaire qui seront
candidats aux élections municipales
prochaine laura normales seront alors
tenus de dire dans un débat politique
local
s'ils comptent aller au terme de leur
éventuel nouveau mandat de maire est
donc abandonner leur mandat
parlementaire en 2017 ou si non s'il
compte proposer une succession en cours
de mandat et à qui on m'a votre ami
manuel valls vous pose la question quasi
directement vous maire d'alfortville
sénateurs parce que vous allez choisir
quand vous allez vous présenter devant
les habitants elles font jouer leur dire
quoi
quand je vous dis que j'ai pas la langue
de bois même si vous nous avez passé
manuel valls à la commission des lois et
dans ce qu'il dit je ne crois pas que le
débat municipal va se poser comme ça en
tout les comme dans ma ville se pose pas
comme ça le débat municipal c'est le
ministre de l'intérieur il le dit que
les parlementaires auront à dire si le
reste maire ou pas moi en tous les cas
comme sénateur et maire je vais emmener
une équipe sur un projet et le débat
pour moi de 2014
c'est d'avoir la confiance d alfortville
asie d alfortville est pour que le
projet que j'en propose soit mis en
oeuvre
on n'a pas la réponse parce que mon
capitaine pardon de l'expression
je me bats et là aussi j'enfonce pas une
porte ouverte puisque chacun c'est ma
position par rapport au sénat la chambre
des collectivités pour que le sénat
puisse se conserver un mandat exécutif
local et le mandat de sénateur parce que
on dit beaucoup
je veux dire je vais faire deux
remarques on va voter une loi on va la
beauté et moi d'ailleurs je fais partie
des 37 % des militants socialistes en
2010 qui avait voté le texte d'arnaud
montebourg
sauf qu'on a tous oublié ce qu'on a voté
on a voté un statut de l'élu et non
cumul des mandats on a tous oublié les
conclusions de la commission jospin 15
pages sur le non cumul qui conclut par
un paragraphe qui dit rien ne pourra se
faire sans voter avant tout et urgemment
un statut de l'élu
il n'y a pas de statut les quais les
choses là c'est très simple le maire ou
sénateur maire cslc jeu concours pour
être maire en 2014 en jeu ce père que
j'aurai la confiance engagé à quitter
votre mandat de sénateur et à mener
jusqu'au bout votre mandat de maire je
mènerai jusqu'au bout au mandat de
sénateur il faut il faut du temps pour
avoir la réponse selon manuel valls main
avoir du travail
et parce que et parce que la question se
pose pas comme ça et que des malais
randonnée la loi s'appliquera en 2017 et
vous aurez forcément choix à faire il
vous aura pas échappé que la loi est en
discussion à l'assemblée qu'elle va
arriver en discussion septembre au sénat
oui je ne sais pas ce qu'il y aura dans
cette loi je ne sais pas de quelle
manière elle sera ou pas amendée donc
vous comprenez que cela appuyé un petit
peu plus je suis sur la ligne du
président du groupe françois rebsamen
je ne m'en cache pas je l' ai toujours
dit je pense qu'il cette ligne même
plutôt assez majoritairement groupe
socialiste voilà ce n'est pas un sujet
s'il le faut ça les doigts ne passera
pas eu le temps d'avoir une vision
institutionnelle différentes
ce n'est pas insultant nous sommes dans
notre rôle est la seule chose que je
veux dire puisque le seul étendard con
mais par rapport au non cumul des
mandats c'est le renouvellement de la
classe politique
moi je vais vous dire j'ai 42 ans je
suis le plus jeune maire de mon
département est un des plus jeunes
sénateurs du sénat ma chance peut-être
c'est d'avoir rencontré un homme
politique rené rouquet qui a fait le
organiser le passage de témoin la vraie
modernité politique aurait été de faire
la limitation du cumul des mandats dans
le temps et non pas ce mandat
si on comprend bien ce que vous êtes
contre l'interdiction du cumul
en a des tas proche de manuel valls est
lui qui met ça en place mais vous êtes
comme moi je suis pour le mandat
exécutif local et un mandat de
parlementaire
limité dans les parages je vous dis je
n'y connais très bien la position
je suis pour un mandat exécutif local un
mandat national limiter à deux mandats
dans le temps limité dans le temps avec
l'interdiction de cumuler les indemnités
de fonction voilà qui a été ma position
voilà ce que je défendrai au sein du de
ligny cycle au sénat mais en même temps
je ne sera pas 100 mais en tous les cas
moi je suis aussi quelqu'un de très
légitimiste et je ferai ce que le groupe
socialiste au sénat décidera de faire
mais on aura les débats au mois de
septembre
c'est en ce sens que les débats vont
être animés landes est alors passé jeudi
c'est un honneur de la grande conférence
sociale c'est désormais une tradition
c'est une grande messe du dialogue
social qui a lieu ce jeudi ouverte par
le président françois hollande
elle rassemble l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux l'an dernier le
climat était plutôt sera pour la
deuxième édition les positions vous
allez le voir août un petit peu évolué
et rim benameur grande priorité pour
cette deuxième conférence sociale
l'emploi françois hollande qui donne le
coup d'envoi du grand rendez-vous il
consacre donc une bonne partie de son
discours plus de 10% de la population
active sont aujourd'hui privés d'emploi
3 millions de demandeurs cinq vidéos ont
su nous prenons toutes les catégories ce
tag achi pour l'économie parmi les
annonces à retenir
cent mille contrats d'avenir à la fin de
l'année le développement de l'alternance
et un plan d'action sur les quelques
200000 emplois non pourvus mais cette
conférence c'est aussi le lancement
d'une réforme explosive celle des
retraites
première option augmenter l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite
ça a été fait c'était le principe de la
réforme de 2010 j'ai considéré que ça
revenait à pénaliser ceux qui ont
commencé tôt à travailler
l'autre option
c'est de prolonger la durée de
cotisation c'est la mesure la plus juste
à condition de l'appliquer à tous à la
sortie du discours présidentiel
les syndicats sont sur leur faim et un
de bien nouveau dans le discours du
président de la république
il a confirmé que selon lui sur le
dossier retraites l'une des pistes ce
sera d'augmenter la durée de cotisation
je le dis pour force ouvrière c'est nous
il nous a pas rassurés sur la
préoccupation première de français qui
est le salaire puisqu'il n'a même pas
évoqué la question de la rémunération
des salariés dans ce pays il n'a pas
évoqué la question du montant des
pensions pour la prêter qui est une
question est également importante place
ensuite aux six tables rondes suivant la
même méthode que la première conférence
l'occasion pour les partenaires sociaux
de défendre leurs arguments
j'ai répété très précisément qu'il
s'agissait d'un enjeu majeur qu'il
fallait cesser le mensonge qui a été dit
aux français depuis plusieurs décennies
et qui laisse entendre que son mouvement
significatif sur l'âge légal
on pourra maintenir notre niveau de
pension
compétitivité c'est faux la nouvelle
feuille de route social sera publié dès
la fin de la conférence
il s'agit d'aller vite pour le
gouvernement avec une négociation cet
été entre partenaires sociaux
et dès la rentrée de lois une sur les
retraites et une sur la formation
professionnelle alors dans vos
prérogatives vous avez aussi la gestion
et le lire avec les syndicats vous avez
consulté vous avez été consultés pour
cette grande messe sociale ou pas au
parti socialiste harlem désir a mis en
oeuvre des rencontres avec les syndicats
donc nous sommes en train de rencontrer
les partenaires sociaux mais la c1 dans
le rapport entre le parti socialiste et
les syndicats
ce n'est pas là pour venir parasiter ce
qui a été mis en oeuvre il y avait
aujourd'hui et nous allons essayer
d'accompagner évidemment le processus
mais ce qui est important c'est ce qui
se passe depuis deux jours ce qui est
important c'est encore une fois le
pardon de discours de la méthode où on
est face à un exécutif un président un
gouvernement qui dès son élection leur
élection ont cherché à rouleaux et
finalement le fils du dialogue
quand on sait ce que le précédent
gouvernement disait des corps constitués
et cette méthode elle fonctionne entre
les fonctionne vraiment parce que le
verdict concernant réussi à voter
l'année oui les désaccords sur la nive
zelda wii mais on réussit est d'accord
avec ça c'est une position majoritaire
dans les syndicats même si ce qui était
mis en minorité créer un peu plus fort
que les autres
on a quand même réussi à avoir des
avancées donc c'est cette bien c'est
bien cette méthode là il cet accord sur
l'emploi on est d'accord avec ça
simplement ce que je vais vous expliquer
c'est que les syndicats disent françois
hollande nous fait un discours très bien
sauf que derrière il va discuter avec le
patronat c'est le patronat qui a raison
de nous pouvons y avec les syndicats sa
merci mais non les syndicats sont bons
le rôle qu'on ait dit ça à un patron de
syndicats s'il ne disait pas ça il
serait pas à sa place donc moi ça me
choque pas maintenant le présent la
république a ouvert cette conférence
sociale a guidé choses donc il faut
regarder maintenant comment au sortir
des tables rondes la conclusion de cet
après midi mais c'est la conclusion de
deux jours ensuite et personnes sur
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
on est d'accord et là il a annoncé
d'entrée ça c'était quelque chose de
déjà acté de lui
public donne des pistes et des élus
aussi pardon dans son rôle
un moment donné le sujet c'est bien de
sauver notre régime de retraite d'accord
mais les concertations sur les retraites
c'est une décision je pense que elle
n'étonne personne
d'ailleurs si elle étonnée quelques-uns
il n'y aurait pas déjà d'organiser avant
la mi-septembre des manifestations
parent ou moins un syndicat
donc qu'on ne nous dise pas qu'on
découvre la ligne du président mais
encore une fois on va avoir pendant les
deux mois de l'été des discussions des
choses on se dire on va voter des lois
on connaissait bien les syndicats ils
ont lu le rapport moreau ils ont lu les
pistes ce que vous sentez des données
dans lequel ils ne céderont pas je pense
par exemple au mode de calcul des
retraites des fonctionnaires
oui mais là aussi je crois que depuis
deux jours des choses ont été dites par
rapport aux tous les cas des pistes
évoquées sur le fait dehors continue à
distinguer publics et privés sur le mode
de calcul et le rapport mourou ce n'est
pas la loi
là aussi c'est important d'avoir des
spécialistes qui produisent des rapports
pour ce que l'on appelle chez nous les
politiques l'aide à la décision sauf que
aux yeux de nos concitoyens il faut pas
qu'ils pensent que comme un rapport est
remis
il fait force de loi il est là pour
éclairer des débats les syndicats
notamment dans le rapport moreau sur le
calcul de la des fonctionnaires disait
de points sur les dix ans plus tôt les 6
dernies voilà donc là aussi je n'ai pas
le sentiment qu'on va aller sur les
attendus du rapport mots tous les cas
que les inflexions les infections ne
vont pas vers versa donc on est dans un
process qui contrairement à ce que dit
l'ump mon collègue karoutchi qui sera
fière que nous discutons beaucoup pour
pas grand chose
nous avançons avec la sérénité surtout
le respect de tous et ce qui est
important c'est que chacun puisse
trouver là sa place y compris que dans
le patronat les uns et les autres
puissent être coordonnés et aide les
bons représentants qu on n où l'exécutif
en face d'une houle et les représentants
le plus le plus complet de
ceux qui sont censés représenter les
employeurs et les employés parce que ça
aussi ça doit être un sujet en tête de
tous les quarts d'heure vous savez on va
changer de sujet bien sûr vous savez que
à bientôt célébrer le centenaire de la
première guerre mondiale à cette
occasion et bien le sénat a décidé
d'ouvrir ses archives et vous pouvez
également les consulter sur internet et
pour la première fois une caméra a pu
s'introduire dans les archives du sénat
regardez c'est dans un an que les
commémorations du centenaire de la
première guerre mondiale débuteront et
ont manqué d'archivés sur le rôle du
sénat durant cette période dans cette
perspective le sénat a mis plusieurs
mois à numériser quarante mille pages
inédites
il conservait depuis l'époque de la
grande guerre eh bien vous vous trouvez
ici dans un des locaux des archives du
sénat où sont conservés tous les
documents qu'ils auront trait aussi bien
aux missions du sénat institutionnel que
à son organisation administrative
ce sont des noms aussi prestigieux dans
l'histoire de france que ceux de georges
clemenceau alexandre millerand ou paul
doumer qui apparaissent au fil des pages
il y avait bien sûr certains qui était
sénateur et d'autres qui avaient des
responsabilités gouvernementales mais
qui ont été auditionnés par les
commissions du sénat
quels que soient leur renommée ces
différentes personnalités
gouvernementales sont donc interrogés et
contrôlés par des commissions
parlementaires
celles ci vont devenir permanente avec
la guerre alors que jusqu'à présent elle
était exceptionnelle l'intérêt est très
grand puisque c'est le moment où le
sénat va développer sa fonction de
contrôle à l'égard de la politique menée
par le gouvernement et il va vouloir le
contrôler dans tous les aspects de la
conduite du conflit que ce soit
stratégique militaire ou pour les
questions techniques et matérielles ce
programme est beaucoup plus large
puisqu'il s'inscrit dans la numérisation
complète des archives de la haute
chambre après la 5e et la quatrième
c'est au tour des archives de la
troisième république d'être numérisée et
dans quelques jours les débats en séance
seront eux aussi mis en ligne bientôt
vous pourrez voir aussi les images de
ces séances séance de commission et
c'est la première fois au moment de
cette guerre que les commissions eu
cette importance est aujourd'hui quelque
chose qu'on
doit pas vraiment l'habitude de voir
important c'est quelque chose de très
très important ht par an franchement je
trouve ça extraordinaire tellement
l'historien de formation qui parle mais
je trouve ça extrêmement +1 c1
ça nous rappelle notre histoire et c'est
très important et 2 ça aussi remet
complètement dans le rôle de ce qu'elle
sénat en matière de contrôle et
d'ailleurs l'avenir du parlement
français il va être dans sa dans le
contrôle et du législateur et c'est pour
ça qu'on a créé une nouvelle commission
des lois présidée par david assouline
qui est en charge du contrôle de
l'application des archives pour les
autres grands événements français on
pense à la guerre de 39-45 question tous
les cas là on est dans ce qu'avait
promis le président de la république en
son temps en 2011 pour les
commémorations du centenaire de la
grande guerre je trouve ça vraiment pour
les plus jeunes générations de pouvoir
leur dire comment nos perles et nos
arrière grands pères ont vécu tout cela
et comment à l'époque les politiques de
l'époque ont géré ce conflit ça fait
plus que oeuvres utile moi je trouve
cette opération back comprendre le
présent par le passé va quitter sur ces
mots et nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine merci beaucoup d'avoir